[Música]
christoph kraemer futbolista alemán
sufrió una conmoción cerebral durante la
final de la copa del mundo brasil 2014
al chocar con el defensor argentino
ezequiel garay igualmente queremos
recuperar la conciencia en los pocos
minutos pero no recuerdo haber jugado
aquel partido
si se acuerda del antes y el después
ahora del durante esos 30 minutos más
importantes como futbolista profesional
se imaginan digo insisto nos recuerda
haber juego una final del mundo se
imaginan alcanzar semejante logro de
olvidarse lo
ahora se abre torres futbolista y
director técnico argentino con varios
clubes dirigen otros tantos tuvo una
buena carrera con un gran gran
sobresalto en el 63 cuando dirigió nada
más y nada menos que
selección argentina la dirigió en una
copa américa y en una copa roca la copa
roca en un desafío de ida y vuelta
contra el brasil que ya no se hace más
que los brasileros siempre nos ganaban
no lo sé el tema es que en uno de esos
partidos la selección comandada por
ahora se ganó tres a dos en san pablo al
brasil de pelé un brasil que además de
tener a uno de los mejores jugadores de
la historia entre sus titulares como lo
fue pelé y de ser local venía de ser
campeona del mundo el año anterior en
chile 62 sin embargo horacio al igual
que kramer no recuerdo a su logro
profesional más importante pero no por
un choque sino por una enfermedad a
partir de los 60 años ahora se empezó a
sufrir de alzhéimer así que toda su
carrera deportiva empezó a caer
lentamente en el olvido e incluso su
logro le ganó la pelea se imaginan
alcanzar semejante logro de olvidarse lo
el alzheimer no es olvidarse sólo de
cosa del pasado de recuerdos es una
enfermedad mucho más compleja
neurodegenerativa es olvidarse de todo
comer hablar caminar
realmente una carrera contra el tiempo
porque vendría a ser como volver a hacer
bebés sin tener el tiempo para aprender
todas esas cosas en este caso en el de
horacio y su carrera contra el tiempo lo
último que se llevó el alzheimer fueron
sus recuerdos futbolísticos
sorprendentemente podría no recordar que
había cenado la noche anterior pero sí
que había dirigido a césar luis menotti
y carlos salvador bilardo quizás no los
ubiquen como jugadores pero estoy casi
seguro de que los tienen como directores
técnicos porque fueron los técnicos
campeones del mundo en argentina 78 y
mexico 86 respectivamente
el fútbol le devolvía la vitalidad de
oración sus recuerdos futbolísticos le
olían su vitalidad
tanta observación médica pero no soy
médico lejos lejos de serlo soy
periodista pero antes que cualquier
título o profesión soy su nieto
y les garantizo que cuando hablamos de
fútbol podíamos charlar sino más que
nada conectar cuando hablamos de fútbol
el tiempo parecía detenerse
el chico que siempre cuenta su historia
porque nunca nadie la conocía en el
primario en la escuelita de fútbol ni en
inglés ni el secundario nunca nadie
conocía gracia amable torresi a mí
me irritaba no podía entender cómo la
conocían a mi abuelo de un director
técnico de la selección argentina de
fútbol el deporte más popular del país
no es nacional porque alguien quiso que
fuera el pato a no saber por qué
conscientemente de chico por culpa de
gracia que ejerce la profesión llenarlo
de preguntas y repreguntas fue la manera
en la que
en la que él me acerco al periodismo
y a través de sus recuerdos nos
comunicábamos nos relacionamos y por qué
no combatimos al alzheimer porque como
les dije antes cuando hablamos de fútbol
el tiempo parecía detenerse y por ende
la enfermedad también la poníamos en
pausa y la mandamos a un costado
estamos hechos y atravesados de
historias con la oración comprendía el
poder que pueden tener los recuerdos en
nosotros gracias a los suyos me interesé
y aprendí tanto del periodismo como del
fútbol
el periodismo aprendí los conceptos de
preservar y visibilizar una historia
pero más que nada que las fuentes no son
para siempre
las fuentes son finitas son humanas
pueden sufrir una conmoción cerebral
pueden sufrir un alzhéimer
puede ser un libro quemado o una hoja
por día
a dónde fue a parar todo lo que tenía
para contar oración
alzheimer's hecho un montón de preguntas
sin contestar
y dirigir a la selección ocho partidos
se considera un fracaso
alguien con 36 años de edad con la que
asumió
a la dirección técnica de la selección
está capacitado para semejante puesto
como la la fa la 60 si se puede hacer
alguna comparación con la actual como
era minotti como jugador como el a
bilardo en fin un montón de preguntas
que no sólo hubiesen generado material
periodístico sino más que nada
conversación y eso la conversación todo
lo que se genera alrededor de un hecho
en sí es lo que me enseña la historia de
gracia sobre el fútbol que el fútbol no
es más que una excusa una excusa para
compartir porque es un deporte que
trasciende los límites de la cancha para
instalarse en cualquier charla del café
bar oficina bueno una sala con familia o
amigos por ejemplo
con mis amigos salimos campeones del
torneo internacional acá en el colegio
en primer año
no no no se gasten en encontrarme no me
van a encontrar mi alter ego deportivos
no usan de ojos pero bueno si insiste en
abajo a su derecha alguien con una
vincha tapándole toda la frente a y ese
soy yo pero bueno recapitulando fuimos
el peor mejor equipo porque fuimos los
peores de los peores en la zona de grupo
y no me pregunten como resultados son
los campeones mágicamente insisto no
pregunten cómo terminamos arriba
lo seguimos recordando con mis amigos
saltan puntos que nada la clasificación
es cada vez más épica los partidos más
gloriosos los goles cada de mago lazos y
si seguimos así les digo que estamos a
esto me gana la copa del mundo
ya pasaron cuántos más de diez años
aquella hazaña que nos marcó tanto como
amigos que sus recuerdos intactos
exagerado tal vez puede ser pero bueno
intacto al fin igualmente no los culpo
digo a ver cuántos de nosotros
recordamos las historias exagerando las
cada vez más
es hermoso recuerdo del secundario
refleja mi relación con horacio porque
nuestra comunicación a través de
recuerdos que iban distorsionando se por
culpa de la enfermedad
lamentablemente a mi abuelo lo conocí
con alzheimer así que
correr del tiempo mis preguntas serán
las mismas pero no sus respuestas por
suerte los datos son irrefutables así
que nunca puedo engañarme con eso que
juegan river y hay otra elección del
periodismo hay que chequear y reciclar
los datos la verdad que me gusta lo que
hago estoy muy contento en parte de
gracias a él así que celebráis con
nuestra manera charlando recordando
contando una historia
para que su logro
y así como los recuerdos del fútbol en
mi caso tienen el poder para seguir
fortaleciendo
mi relación con los chicos también
tuvieron el poder para acercarme a mi
abuelo combatirá en el ceimar
interesarme en el fútbol y en el
periodismo
pero más que nada los recuerdos me dan
el poder de
de volver a tener presente oración por
un ratito no le voy a mentir
pero bueno dijo que me voy que me junto
con los chicos a ver si de una vez por
todas ganamos esa copa del mundo gracias
[Aplausos]